[Music]
managing this complexity feels quite
overwhelming
whereas when come into cloud you wanna
your infrastructure to work flawlessly
ride the cloud manage the interest
groups on compute engine help you handle
all of the problems above automatically
and build highly available and scalable
applications and also roll out the
updates automatically and safely for you
so that you can have a peace of mind
knowing that your application is well
taken care of today we're going to talk
about how to build your applications on
top of many census groups how to deploy
them how to build scalable and highly
available stateless load-balanced
application and also how to scale a
batch pool of workers and if you are
already familiar with the managed iNSYS
group we have some pro tips for you so
let's start first from the application
deployment you have your continuous
integration continuous deployment
pipeline that produces a software built
at the end and you could package this
software in three ways into a container
image you could make a boot image with
all of your application and library
spring style this could maybe give you a
faster startup time or you could use a
simple startup script that would install
your dependencies and software on a VM
boot any of these methods work with
managing sis groups however for the this
presentation let's look at an example of
how would you deploy application in a
container image it is very easy you
don't and only takes two steps first you
are create a virtual machine and then
you check the check box that you want to
deploy container to this machine specify
your container image and docker runtime
parameters for example restarts policy
you or you could pass some environment
variables to your container and that's
it what will happen net next is that
compute engine will create a virtual
machine for you this machine is going to
be based on a container
my operating system that has docker
pre-installed and also a container
startup agent that will start your
container on vm boot so you don't need
to write any scripts to start the
container yourself and in addition to
all of that the container optimized
operating system image is supported and
maintained by Google so you can always
use and get the image with the latest
update and security patches to create
your new machines and if one VM is not
enough you can create a group of
machines with the container first you
would create an instance template from a
container image and then you would
create a manage since this group from
this template that would then scale and
create as many VMs as you need and if
your application is load balancing you
can attach it to a load balancer let's
look at how it works in practice
ok so first of all we need to pull the
template sorry a container into a Google
cloud registry a Google container
registry so we could then use it so you
can do it with a simple docker push
command so let's go to the container
registry I've put a container before
representation so let's copy the path to
the container and now let's click create
a template so compute engine template
let's call it the container GCE
let's provide an URL to a container and
that's allow HTTP traffic because our
container has a simple web server that
is serving application so we can verify
that it works after it's been put up so
now we have a template ready so now
let's move to the instance groups and
create an instance group
zon now we have to choose a template
that we've created previously you can
turn on auto scaling for now to not be
just we can set the any number of
instances that we want and create so now
we can see that management of the group
is being created so it usually takes a
little time so refresh it should be
ready by now yeah and we can already see
that in each instance group is created
and it's cleaning up so let's go here we
can see that all the three VMS are up
and running but remember that we have a
container so the container needs to be
downloaded set up there is also a
firewall so if you want to look at the
details what's happening inside the VM
you can go to the serial port console
and we can see that the IP table rules
are being set up it's now it's pulling
the container from the registry you can
see that the container is being
downloaded then it being set up so it's
up and running somewhere else verify if
everything works and it's ready
actually McClure
so in this simple demo we have deployed
a stateless application on multiple
virtual machines now let's look how do
we make this application highly
available and scalable first a good
example of a stateless application would
be a web front-end such as online store
you want it to be highly available so
that your users don't get HTTP 500 when
checking out while shopping and you want
to be scalable so that you can get all
the business that comes your way on
Black Friday and it's worth noting that
stateless means that you manage your
machines like a herd of sheep you care
about the size but you can easily
replace one machine with another they
all do the same thing and they don't
preserve any state past VM lifetime so
let's go back to the problems that we
have discussed in the beginning what
what to do when your application may
stop responding or crash manage instant
groups offer auto healing for that it
promptly detects machines with failed
application and Rick race them for you
automatically so that users are served
again and you don't need to get page in
such a situation it's all handled how
the healing is configured very easy all
you need to do is to configure a health
check for your manager instance group
the way the health check works is that
it pings your each machine on a
specified path and protocol import let's
say my app is TTP 80 it pings it on
regular intervals let's say every 5
seconds and it expects HTTP 200 response
within the latency that you predefined
and if the response is not HTTP 200 or
if it takes longer than 3 seconds then
the fails check is considered failed and
if this health check fails multiple
times the VM is considered as unhealthy
and will be taken care of or recreated
by outer healing from the instance
template where you have your well tested
and stable configuration so that it can
serve you users again it's also worth
noting that health check not just works
with HTTP protocol but also with a chip
yes TCP and SSL so it can be configured
in a very flexible way now load balancer
also uses health checking service that
is configured it's in exactly the same
way the difference though is that load
balancer does not send new traffic to
the virtual machines that are unhealthy
and sends traffic to the machines that
are healthy while original or managed in
this group would recreate a machine
there isn't healthy which is very
different for that reason we highly
recommend using different health check
for a load balancer and managed instance
groups imagine the situation when you
have a machine that is serving at full
capacity so it cannot receive any new
connections and would be unhealthy from
a load balancer perspective so that load
balancer needs to redirect traffic
somewhere else however it is still
healthy from the Institut perspective
because it is still serving well it's
car insertion sessions the app is the
application is up and running and if you
configure a more aggressive health check
for a load balancer let's say you do
shorter check intervals or shorter
response timeouts you will allow a lot
balancer to redirect traffic to a less
busy VMs at the same time out of healing
will wait a bit and we'll let the VM
finish the current sessions and become
available again before it makes the
final decision to recreate the VM
another tip for you is make sure to set
initial delay for out the healing to
longer than it takes for your
application to start serving during the
initial period that starts when the VM
is created out of human will not
recreate machine even this if it isn't
healthy this is to let your application
time to boot and of course while it's
starting in issue analyzing it's not
serving so it's not gonna pass any
health checks and you don't want it to
be recreated by Auto healing so if you
set the initial delay to a higher value
then it takes very application to boot
how to heal anyone will only recreate
your VM if it is unhealthy because
application has failed and not because
it just hasn't started yet
let's look at how are the healing works
okay so we hover we have our instance
group let's look at how it looks like so
we have two VMs before I will I'll show
you how the auto healing works in
practice I need to clarify some things
about this web server application so
this is written as I said for the for
the purpose of this presentation and it
has two functions butene
the first one is reporting the health
status so that will be used to verify
that the VMS healthy and it's serving so
we can verify by clicking here that it
returns response 200 and it's serving so
what I've done is I've put a simple
command that will disable the health
track so it will make VM report stop
reporting the health status as you can
see this is not working so what now out
of healing does is like it pulls the
health status from all the VMS inside
the group to verify that the VMS are
healthy are up and running and
everything is working and if it looks
and fit detects that VM is reporting 500
or the application stopped responding it
will recreate it we can also look how
outer hitting is set up so you go into
the console health tracks we have an
outer healing so as you can see we are
looking at the path health so the same
as I've shown you before on the
application it's using its using
protocol HTTP but you can use TCP HTTP
as SSL on any port you want you need to
specify interval timeout and the number
of consecutive failures etc so let's go
back to the instance group and as you
can see VM has been detected that it's
failing so it's being recreated
automatically by the managed instance
group
all right so now we have a group of
virtual machines that are running and if
an application fails it will be
automatically detected and the VM will
be recreated by out the healing great
but what if a bigger a bigger problem
happens and the application fails in an
entire zone in this case of the healing
won't help because the root cause of the
problem is likely not on a single VM but
is related to zonal configuration so to
protect your application against such
situation you would use a regional
managed in this group and distribute
your machines across multiple zones so
that should a single zone fail your
application can still serve from the
other available zone and the load
balancer will redirect traffic to the
healthy virtual machines in those zones
you cannot hear on this picture that
however you will get only two-thirds of
your capacity remaining in the case of
zone failure and if you care about your
hive availability so much that you want
to have enough machines to serve your
expected load even in case of zonal
failure you should make sure that these
two-thirds cover that requirements and
in this case you would need to provision
extra VMs let's take a look at the
example imagine like at this picture you
need nine VMs to serve your traffic so
in order to protect you against tunnel
failure and still have sufficient yams
you need to create more extra VMs so
that shooters don't fail you have in
this case 10 VMs available which is more
than nine and enough to cover your
expected load calculating how many VMs
you need to over provision to protect
your workload against on failure is easy
all you need to do is to divide the
number of the VMS you need by the number
of the remaining available zones so for
example if you deploy your group to
three different zones you need to add
50% more VMs that you regularly expect
from your
Lord this way you would protect it let's
see how original managed instance group
work okay so let's go to our original
manage instance group so as you can see
we have three sounds B C and F and each
zone we have two instances up and
running so there is also a load balancer
configured so you have to go to
networking services load balancing
balancer and here is the IP of the load
balancer so we can query the balancer
and see that on each refresh different
VMs serving so this application gives
you as you can see the the hostname that
the sound that the VM is in and the
template is used that it will be used
for for the purpose of the later
presentation so what I've done I've
written a simple script that will query
with load balancing the load balancer I
query all the VMS and get the current
zone that the VM is in and will report
it on the screen so let's run it so as
you can see all the VMS are up and
running or are serving from all zones so
now what we can do is like simulate the
zone failure so of course I will not
bring down the zone during the
presentation by I can simulate it by
disabling health checks the savings are
deserving the start making the VMS
report and healthy status so let's do it
sable central one and let's disable down
F like disable the VM since on there is
troll okay so now the the health track
is configured the same as in previous
demo so we need few seconds to load
sir to see that the VM stopped
responding as you can see it happens
quite fast so now our traffic is served
only from Zone B ends on C so we can
let's bring down another zone
so it for few more seconds and as you
can see only vm's from Zone C are
serving so now let's bring back all the
zones back
so what happens is outer healing
sorry the load balancer queries the
health status of the VMS and if he ends
report start reporting that there are
healthy again it will redirect traffic
back to the back to those VM so as you
can see we got already two zones up and
running and the third one will be
brought back and in a matter of seconds
like ten o'clock alright so now we have
a group of VMs where if a single
application fails it gets automatically
recreated and it is protected against
zonal failure because the VMS in the
other zones can still serve back to the
problems but what if the load spikes and
lands on insufficient capacity you don't
want to lose business because of that or
what if the load goes down and you have
idling VMs you don't want to pay extra
for those autoscaler of the many census
groups make sure that the group has
enough instances to serve the Lord that
you have an adjusted group size in the
real-time contingent auto scaling is
also fairly simple you turn out to
scaling on in the machines group
configuration choose the scaling metric
that you want to use CPU usage is a very
popular one select the target load for
that metric for example 60% CPU
utilization on average per single
machine and specify constraints so that
autoscaler does not scale beyond this
boundaries the minimum and maximum let's
say you want your group size to be at
least one VM but not exceed 10 instances
and one more important parameter is
cooldown period this is how long and
autoscaler should wait before taking a
machine into account since it started
booting this is important because while
VM is booting it might have good
processes that highly utilize CPU and
which is not representative of the
regular serving Lord and could create a
noise for auto scaling signal
so if you set cooldown period to longer
than it takes for your VM to boot and
stabilize you will make sure that
autoscaler will ignore this Boonton
instances while they're loading and
without this noise from the signal and
there's a result get more accurate group
sizings by the autoscaler let's see how
are the scaling works imagine you have a
group where at the Lord spikes and in
the current number of the VMS the CPU
usage goes significantly above your
target which is 60% in this example
autoscaler will detect the situation and
add more VMS to bring the average load
back to the target value and one of the
over time the load goes down and becomes
lower than your target auto scale will
also detect the situation and will
remove the extra VMS again to bring the
load back to the target a pro tip for
you is if you want to accelerate your
scaling you can you should set up a
lower target value for it to maintain we
can look at this as an example a imagine
you have a three VMs all of which are
overloaded one is that 80% CPU
utilization 70 and 90 and if your target
is 60% the autoscaler will resize it to
4 VMs and if your target is 40% the
autoscaler resize it to 6 vm which is a
faster scaling that you could achieve
also if you use out of scaling together
with regional managed interest groups
make sure that you set a higher maximum
load than you expect for your maximum
demand kind a higher maximum number of
instances then you expect for a maximum
load so that autoscaler has enough room
to scale up to the single zone fail this
is exactly the same formula that you
would use for an auto scaled group the
only difference is that for the non auto
skilled group this formula would be
applied to the target number of VMs on
this extra VMs will be actually
running wares in the auto skills
scenario you would apply this formula to
the maximum boundary for the group size
and the group will reach maximum only
when it is needed in those zones so
let's see how to stack killing works so
we have an instance group with only one
VM that is serving the application to
observe the web application that you've
seen before so as I said this web this
web application has two functions one is
making VMs reports on healthy status and
the second one is during generating the
high load on the CPU so what it does in
the background is multiplying two random
numbers in a loop so we will have a high
CPU utilization so let's start the
function so in the meantime that will
wait for the autoscaler to kick to kick
in let's look how it's set up
so let's open the scalar so we have a
auto scaling set up based on the CPU
usage I've set up the target cpu size to
30% so the autoscaler would spin our VMs
a little bit quicker for this for the
purpose of this presentation is set up
the maximum number to 5 and the cooldown
period to 15 seconds because the web
server is just a simple Python script so
it takes like few seconds to startup
back so as you can see autoscaler is
already detected that the high load on
the under one of the machines and
brought up the additional VMS to
compensate load
all right so now we have highly
available and out of skilled group of
VMs but how do you handle updates how do
you roll out updates in a safe way
making sure that your users don't
experience downgrade of your
self-service Auto updater allows you to
roll out an update in a safe way and in
multiple different scenarios and do it
automatically when you do an update you
want to at the end of the day get your
group from an old version to a new
version and the actual update is all
about the journey from that and you can
configure this and automate this journey
with the following configuration options
for the auto updater the first one is
you set up how far would you like to
roll out the update how many machines
would you like to update you could
decide that you want to update half of
the machines or maybe the entire group
the second option is how many machines
do you update at a single time to roll
out the update carefully you don't
necessarily want to update all of them
at the same time you want to update one
or two check if that they work in and
proceed the third option is how many
extra machines do you want to create any
new versions temporarily this is useful
when you don't want to take any of the
service serving machines in the old
version down for an update and would
rather keep them serving as the yard
create the machines in the new version
on the side wait until they are healthy
and start serving and only then remove
the old machines you can also configure
how long an updater should wait for the
machine in the new version to boot and
stabilize to make sure that it is truly
healthy and only then proceed to update
in the next patch you can also configure
update action by default it is a
recreation of a VM from a new instance
template however you could also use a
rollout strategy with the same instance
template but restart
in the vm's instead this is useful when
updated situated within guest
operating-system
agent such as puppet agent for example
on vm boot and finally you can choose a
bit mode proactive which will roll out
the update automatically or
opportunistic which will on in which
case the updater will only create
machines in the new version when new
machines are really needed for example
when the group is scaled up and it will
only remove the machines in the old
versions when you need to delete the
machines for example when the group
should be sized down so a product for
you is that if you want to update some
specific machines that is specific time
and do it manually
you could set up a new instance template
for your group set update mode to
opportunistic and then recreate those
specific VMs at the time when you want
it updater would treat the creation is
an opportunity for update and this VMs
will be created from the new instance
template let's look at what kind of
scenarios you could build with this
configuration rolling update is a very
popular one this is when you need to
roll out a patch to your whole group or
maybe a new feature to all of your users
so you want the updater allowed to the
entire group new template 100% however
you want to roll it out safely let's say
you want to update three machines at a
time wait until they are up and if they
don't pass the health check stop the
update you can do debugging or maybe
decide to roll it back and if they do
pass the hash chip by the health check
proceed to the next three and then the
next three and so on until the whole
group is updated another useful scenario
is canary update this is useful when you
want to do a/b testing let's say you
have an online web store and you need to
roll out a feature that is expected to
increase your conversion to sales so you
would set the new template to let's say
30% and wait for a week or a month until
you collect enough statistics to make a
decision whether the conversion
has indeed improved and whether you
should proceed with the further allowed
or roll it back the beauty of the
cannery update is that the Minish
managed instance group will keep this
ratio for you as the group scales you
don't need to do anything extra on your
own so let's look at how data works okay
so we have an instance group that has
six VMs all the VMS were created from
the first version of our application so
we can see that all of them have
instance template number one as a source
so to make this demo a little bit more
interesting let's use another
application that we've written for the
purpose of this presentation so it
queries the VMS via the API and gets the
current status of a VM it can be
creating restarting deleting recreating
and it will also show you the version of
the instance template that is used to
create it so as you can see all the VMS
are in version one so now let's do a
rolling update let's do a cannery update
were running fashion so let's choose
that we want to have our second version
of our application to be rolled out to
30% of our VMs but we want to do it in a
gradual way so we want to only bring
down one VM at the time and provision
additional one VM at the same time so we
would not pay too much for the
additional vm said but at the same time
we'll keep the the pool of the VMS in a
stable way so let's update
and as you can see the first VM started
to be deleted at the same time the
second VM that we wanted to provision
it's already being created
so creating VMs is a little bit faster
than deletion mmm let's wait for a few
seconds it's usually it takes about half
a minute so as you can see first VM is
already up and running with the version
2 of the template and as soon as second
VM was created the another VM is
bringing brought down and we are just
waiting for the first VM to be deleted
once the first VM is deleted we'll spin
up additional VM and the process
continues we can also verify here that
the first VM is already let's refresh
the UI console is a little bit slower
than our application so as you can see
the this one this VM is being deleted we
already have two VMs with instance
template oh so here's one here is the
second one and we can also verify that
we have two VMs in the new version and
the rest of the rest two are being
deleted
all right another useful update scenario
is a fast rollout without reduction in
service this is useful when you need to
roll out an update your entire group
however the you cannot afford taking
down any of the existing instances I
don't rather create them on the side so
you could set the new template two
hundred percent because you want to roll
out the update to the whole group you
set max and available to zero so that it
doesn't update any of the serving old
instances and you said max search 200%
in this case the Amana census group will
create the instances in the new version
on a side wait until they pass the
health check and start serving and only
then will remove the old instances as
you can see with all of these settings
you can build quite a flexible and
automated update scenario that works for
you it will roll out the update if the
new version is passed as the health
check and is serving well and it will
stop the update and let you intervene if
if something is wrong and the new
instances are not passing the health
checks now it's all good but how does
updater work without the healing good
for example when you roll out an update
and in all the instance fails could it
exceed to your marks an available budget
the answer is no let's look at an
example assume you set max and available
to two and update started rolling out it
updated to VM successfully all good
but then all VM fails and is being out
of healed update or knows about it and
reduces its maximal budget to one so it
will only take one more instance for
update and at the end you will get a one
instance updated to the new version and
the all the instance out to healed and
serving so updated on how to healing
work well together
how about updater and auto scaling good
update rollout interfere with the auto
scaling calculations let's look at an
example let's say updater took down two
machines for
date with the constants Lord this would
lead to a temporary increase in the
average load for the remaining serving
machines however how the healer is aware
about this to VMT are being recreated
and will take them into account when
calculating the desired number of the
machines for the whole group so it won't
provision any extra machines beyond what
you need and will wait for this machines
to put up so updater now to scale in
coordinated their work and work well
together when rolling out and update the
original managed in this group updater
will roll out the new version evenly
across different zones to distribute the
risk and likewise when removing the old
virtual machines it will also remove
them evenly across the zones finally
when your manual since this group is
load balanced and updater picks a
specific machine to update it will
follow the following process first this
virtual machine will stop receiving new
traffic then it will wait for the
connection draining timeout that is
configured in a load balancer to let the
current session that the since the serfs
finish in a graceful way then it will
recreate the instance from the new
template wait until this instance passes
health check and only after that the new
machine will start serving and will
start receiving new traffic and updater
will proceed to the next one so there we
have it we have built a scalable and
highly available application on top of
regional manage in this group that can
be load balanced and the group handles
all of the problems that we've described
above automatically for you
it handles VMs with failed applications
with outer healing it minimizes the
mitigates the impact of zonal failure by
distributing your instances across
multiple zones it makes sure that the
size of your group is tailored to the
variable load that it might
experience and it also allows you to
roll out updates essentially and stop if
you get the unhealthy new version the
main thing is that you can pick any of
these automated services as you need one
of them or multiple of them or all of
them together and do the rest
if you need your custom logic here and
in the end have a peace of mind that
your application is well taken care of
now let's look at how would you scale a
batch pool of workers so okay so what
are the main characteristics of batch
workloads so workers are not needed at
all times because you need it only for
the time of computation so we can bring
the workers down if you don't have
anything to calculate so you optimize
mainly for cost instead of high
availability like in previous
presentation you also scale based on the
number of jobs that are in the queue
instead of for example CPU because if
you have a computations to do like they
are usually very high CPU intensive so
scaling based of the CPU utilization
would not be as good as the scaling base
of the number of jobs so to illustrate
how to put a scaleable provokers for
batch processing let's look at an
example so let's think about an image
stock service so usually what how it
works is like users upload their photos
to the to our service but before putting
the images into the internet we apply
the watermark so it's a perfect example
of batch workload so how architecture
might look like so a user uploads a
photo for a client application for
purpose of the demo that I will show you
in a minute
we save it into the cloud storage when
the image is saved
we also put the name of the image into
the pops up task queue and then we
created a managed instance group that
looks for this pop sub-q watches for the
number of the time for the tasks that
are in there and based on the number of
the task it will scale the application
speed up additional VMS and we have a
process that is running on these VMs
that takes the images from the from the
queue the image names then it downloads
the images applies the watermark and
then uploads them back to the cloud
storage as an output so how it looks
like so you have a small number of users
that are putting images into tech task
queue so we have small number of VMS one
but if the traffic grows so is the
number of dbms but after you process all
the images all the tasks that are in the
pops up cure auto scaling will delete
all of the VMS so you'll not have to pay
for them
Eileen but if you if there will be
another pull of tasks put into the queue
auto scaling will pick pick pick them up
and spit them additional VMS so now
let's take a look at the demo
yeah so as you can see from the previous
dating demo all VMs have been updated so
okay so first of all like I will show
you the images and the rest a little bit
later but first of all let's put some V
games in to allow some images into into
the queue so what this group does is
like pulls all the all the images from
the like all the names of the images
from the from the bucket then put them
into the queue so autoscaler could pick
it up so let's take a look at images so
as I said they are saved into the cloud
storage folder in our project and we
have two folders one is an input that
has images that I've uploaded before the
presentation they were taken from the
recent trip to the Italian Alps as you
can see the images like the views were
quite spectacular and we have also an
output folder that is empty so let's go
back to our manage instance group and
let's see how it is being set up so
we've turned on auto scaling as before
but this time instead of using scaling
based on the CPU we've set up scaling
base of the stock driver monitoring
metric so what we are looking and what
is important here is that that we are
looking at the number of undelivered
messages into the queue the rest is
basically interested in this now and we
have to provide the subscription name so
the autoscaler would know which which
cutolo to watch on and also what is
important that you can specify the
number of tasks per VM so what does it
mean is that outer scaler will take the
number of tests into the Q divided by
the number of tasks the
each VM can process and then spin up the
VMS to process the stuff so if you have
like 10 tasks and you have two tasks per
VM you will have five VMs in the end
auto-scaling
yeah let's refresh and as you can see we
have five VMs processing our images so
we can go back to the queue that's sorry
to the storage and let's see if there
are any images processed yep it's
already working and as you can see we
apply the watermark like GCP next logo
and everything everything is up and
running can you get back to the slides
please yes so and we have also another
queue for tip for you so you can reduce
the cost of your service using the
preemptable VMs which can be up to 80%
cheaper than the usual VMS but there is
a caveat there are usually preempted
lasts up to the VMS last up to 24 hours
that can be preempted in any time but
also a lot of healing will works with
them so Auto healing if the AVMs will be
brought brought down and the auto
healing will watch for the capacity of
preemptable VMs if the capacity becomes
available again it will bring up the VMS
again and also one thing to note that
these VMs will be bringing the road down
gracefully so I will get a 30-second
notice so we can rather run your script
for example on a VM and save your
workload on a disk or like gracefully
close all the connections
so let's bring it all together we have
deployed an application in a container
to a managed instance group we have also
built highly available and scalable
application with the help of outer
healing multi group
Malta's own deployment auto-scaling and
also can update it safely and
automatically and we have built a
scalable batch pool of workers now to
finish I want to leave you with this if
you need to deploy an application to
multiple virtual machines and have full
control over your applications you don't
need to do everything by hand you can
build a highly available and scalable
application by combining the automated
features of the managed tinsel groups
that work for you you're not left on
your own
you
[Music]